[Applause]
there is still a lot of unrest and it's
still a very volatile situation here in
afghanistan evidence of that we are
getting reports of some very serious
disturbances in jalalabad now this is a
very important city to the east of kabul
it's towards the border with pakistan uh
it's a very important trading city and
so on and there has been protests there
about the national flag now since we've
seen the arrival of the taliban they
have
gradually been removing afghanistan's
national flag and replacing it with the
taliban flag we have seen that here in
kabul
a lot of people are not happy with that
a lot of people have been very upset
by that but if they have by and large
had to just put up with it in jalalabad
they have not put up with it there has
been resistance to that by a fairly
sizable
part of the community there and we have
seen
uploaded on social media protests in the
streets of people waving the national
flag really quite large protests of
hundreds if not thousands of people and
we do know
that they have put the flag back up
again in an important square in
jalalabad and that there have been
clashes with the taliban with reports of
gunfire and also that a number of people
have been both killed and injured so
that is still developing but it is a
worrying situation and it is it also
comes at a very uh sensitive time here
it is a day before
afghanistan's independence day so
feelings are running high their tensions
are running high and it has resulted in
what we are seeing to be fatal clashes